لقد مرت ثلاثة أسابيع منذ
فوز الفريق الإسباني لكرة القدم بكأس العالم للسيدات
في أستراليا، لكن القصة منذ
ذلك الحين هيمن عليها
رئيس الاتحاد الإسباني لكرة القدم
لويس روبياليس، وقد ظهر في
الأخبار مرة أخرى لأنه قدم
استقالته أخيرًا إلى  الاتحاد الإسباني لكرة القدم
منذ أن تعرض لانتقادات شديدة
لأنه زرع قبلة غير مرغوب فيها على
شفاه اللاعب جيني هيرموسو
روبياليس ظل في منصبه
لكنه غير لهجته الآن،
كشف روبياليس عن نواياه خلال
مقابلة مع بيرس مورغان، نعم
سأذهب.  لأفعل
نعم، سأفعل نعم لأنني لا أستطيع
مواصلة عملي، ما هي
اللحظة الأخيرة بالنسبة لك، هل كانت تتحدث مع
عائلتك، ربما كان والدك أه نعم،
والدي، وبناتي، التي تحدثت معهم،
أم أنهم لا يعرفون ذلك؟  ليس سؤالاً
عني وعن بعض الأصدقاء
المقربين جدًا مني
ويقولون لي يا لويس الآن
عليك التركيز على هويتك ومواصلة
حياتك
لأنه
إن لم يكن من المحتمل أنك ستذهب إلى هذا
القدر من الأشخاص الذين تحبهم
وقد استقال روبيلز أيضًا من  الاتحاد الأوروبي لكرة القدم،
حيث كان يشغل منصب نائب الرئيس،
كان رحيله له أهمية كبيرة،
وسلوكه وحتى الآن افتقاره إلى
الندم ورفضه تحمل أي
مسؤولية عن ذلك، كل ذلك
أضر بشكل كبير بسمعة
كرة القدم الإسبانية على المسرح العالمي،
وانفجرت الفضيحة في  في الوقت الذي
تسعى فيه إسبانيا للمشاركة في استضافة كأس العالم للرجال
في عام 2030. وفي أعقاب القبلة،
رفض لاعبو إسبانيا اللعب مرة أخرى
للمنتخب الوطني حتى استقالة روبيال أو
إقالته منذ ذلك الحين، وقد
استقال الجهاز الفني بأكمله للفريق في عام 2030.  احتجاجًا
وفي الأسبوع الماضي تم إقالة المدرب الرئيسي خورخي فيلدا
وخلفه
أول مدرب للفريق مونسي تومي،
ويبقى أن نرى ما سيحدث بعد ذلك، لكن
اللاعبات طالبن
بتغيير منهجي في ثقافة كرة القدم
التي يعتقدون أنها معيبة للغاية.  هل سيكون
رحيل الروبيات كافيًا،
أعتقد أننا سنكتشف ذلك قريبًا إليك